That was a good drink. Speaking of drinking things up, welcome to smartless. Smart. So, listener, you've missed ten seconds of this, of this, another attempt at us doing a podcast, where I mentioned how fresh Will looks. And then Will seemed to imply he knew his way around the verbiage of a facial. And I had a facial scheduled for the other day because my wife is. What was the dude's name? Oh, you, my wife's very diligent about getting me a facial,
那杯酒真不错。说到喝东西，欢迎来到Smartless。聪明。所以，听众朋友们，你们错过了这段对话的开头十秒，这是我们录制播客的又一次尝试，当时我提到了威尔看起来气色很好。然后威尔似乎暗示他很懂面部护理的那些术语。我前几天刚好预约了一次面部护理，因为我妻子……那家伙叫什么名字来着？哦，你，我妻子非常热衷于帮我安排面部护理，
making sure I get a facial every, like, six months. And I got to say, I don't push back a lot. Yeah, you know? Because it feels good. It's comfy. It's comfy, it feels good. I feel weird with, you know, I got a tiny bit of prepubescent facial hair on my face. And I wonder if it's, I'm just wasting my time.
确保我每六个月左右做一次面部护理。我得说，我并没有怎么推辞。是啊，你知道吗？因为感觉很舒服。很舒服，感觉很好。我感觉有点怪，你知道，我脸上长了一点点青春期前的胡须。我在想我是不是在浪费时间。
there i don't know with the effectiveness they do a lot of guys like that i i forget to shave a lot of times too but you know uh i just got one last week it was really bad yeah well that's what i was going to ask how how often am i the only guy here um no i get him i get him like once or twice a year but but the last one i had i didn't this is no offense to anybody i just didn't understand a lot of what she said so i she she she was you know i didn't anybody take any offense to that's why i just didn't understand her unless you want to do it imitation of what she sounded like and then we'll decide if it's offensive i do not want to i just am stating a fact i did not understand it's probably my fault i was trying to i was trying to i was trying to drag you
我不知道，考虑到效果，很多男人都喜欢那样，我也经常忘了刮胡子，但你知道，呃，我上周刚做了一次，效果真的很糟糕。是啊，这就是我想问的，我是在座唯一的男人吗？嗯，不，我做，我大概一年做一两次，但我上次做的那个，我没有……这并不是冒犯任何人，我只是不太明白她说的大部分内容，所以我……她……你知道，我没有……任何人别因此感到被冒犯，这就是为什么我只是说我不明白她的话，除非你想模仿一下她的口音，然后我们再决定这是否具有冒犯性。我不想模仿，我只是在陈述一个事实，我没听懂，这可能是我的错，我当时正试图……我正试图……我正试图把你
into deep water let me just can you can you just reveal what continent she may have been from well that's good something eastern eastern asia but not eastern european because it'd be a different accent but if well anyway i feel like i've had a couple facials in my time as well i think i probably had eight total in my life, and I think they've generally been Eastern European bent. That's right. Wait, you're saying, you're in, you're under oath now, sir, you need to understand.
拖进深水区。让我……你能……你能透露一下她可能来自哪个大洲吗？嗯，那很好，东亚，但不是东欧，因为那会是另一种口音。但无论如何，我觉得我这辈子也做过几次面部护理，我想我这辈子总共大概做了八次，而且我觉得它们通常都带有东欧风格。没错。等等，你是说，你现在是在宣誓，先生，你需要明白。
Only eight facials in your life. Maybe 10. Yeah, God, I don't know about that. Really? You don't like them? Yeah, yeah, yeah, I do like them, and it's one of those things. It's kind of like massages. I always forget.
你这辈子只做过八次面部护理。也许10次。是啊，天哪，我不知道。真的吗？你不喜欢它们？是啊，是啊，我喜欢，这就像按摩一样。我总是会忘记。
Yeah, I fall asleep. I do it, and then I go, oh, this is great. How many times have you had your fingers, and toes done. While the facial? No, no, no, no, separate. Are we talking, are we talking Manny Petty? Yeah, Beth.
是啊，我会睡着。我做完之后，会觉得，哦，这太棒了。你做过多少次手指和脚趾护理？在做面部护理的时候？不，不，不，分开的。我们是在说美甲和足疗吗？是啊，贝丝。
Okay. And, uh, I would say, I would say less or more than your face. I got my first, my first time I ever had a pedicure, a manicure was when I was 30, no, but I was about 31, probably 32. Yeah. So it's been, it's been, what, 30 years since then. So it's like 25 years. And so I would say I probably have, I don't know, 25?
好的。而且，呃，我会说，我会说比你做脸的次数多还是少。我第一次做足疗和美甲是在我30岁的时候，不，大概是31岁，可能是32岁。是啊。所以从那时起已经，已经，多少年了，30年了。所以大概是25年。所以我大概做了，我不知道，25次？
So more on the fingers and the toes. Oh, really? Generally not the fingers, generally just the toes because they get kind of gnarly. Right, and my heel gets gnarly. You like an open-toe shoe. I used to, remember I used to wear a lot of flips. Well, you don't wear socks ever.
所以手指和脚趾做的次数更多。哦，真的吗？通常不是手指，通常只是脚趾，因为它们变得有点粗糙。没错，我的脚后跟变得很粗糙。你喜欢穿露趾鞋。我以前喜欢，记得我以前经常穿人字拖吗？嗯，你从来不穿袜子。
And I never wear socks, so my heels get kind of gross. They'd get them cracked. Do you wear underwear? Yes. Okay. Why are we focusing on? Jason never wears his underwear. No, there was a stretch there through a rest of development
而且我从来不穿袜子，所以我的脚后跟变得有点恶心。它们会开裂。你穿内裤吗？穿。好的。我们为什么要关注这个？杰森从来不穿内裤。不，在《发展受阻》拍摄期间有一段时间
where I went to command over some way of reason. And then he would go to the, then he'd wrap his unit in toilet paper for the half an hour, so he'd soak up all the driplets. I was rushing to get back on camera, and I don't want a spot. And then 20 minutes later, like in between setups, he'd like pull out this disgusting toilet paper and put it in a 35-galland trash kit. On set.
我为了某种原因不穿内裤。然后他会去，然后他会用卫生纸把他的“小弟弟”包起来半小时，这样就能吸干所有的水滴。我当时急着回到镜头前，不想留下污点。然后20分钟后，在布景间隙，他会拿出这些恶心的卫生纸，扔进35加仑的垃圾桶里。在片场。
True story. So, wow. So Manny Pettys, often, facial, not so much. Not often. I mean, I probably got one in the spring, Manny Petty. I like going at like 9 a.m. I go to a spot. I've gotten to a few times.
真实故事。所以，哇。所以美甲足疗很频繁，面部护理没那么频繁。不常做。我是说，我可能在春天做过一次美甲足疗。我喜欢在早上9点左右去。我去过一家店几次。
I like going to 9 a.m. This is disgusting. Right when they, by the way, says you, you live like a pampered prince. If people knew how you live. Dude, I don't have a target time. I like to hit my Manny Petty's on, you know, at my, what was at my spot?
我喜欢早上9点去。这太恶心了。顺便说一句，你说你过着养尊处优的生活。如果人们知道你是怎么生活的。伙计，我没有固定的时间。我喜欢在我的美甲足疗店，你知道，在我的，那家店里做。
Is that what you said? I have a spot. I have a spot over here. And it's always fingers and toes at the same time. You ever go in for just the one, one or the other? No. Because you rush for time? Feet.
你是这么说的吗？我有固定的店。我在这边有一家店。而且总是同时做手指和脚趾。你有没有只做其中一项的时候？没有。因为你时间紧？脚。
It's primarily feet. And also, like, because they rub your feet. So it feels nice. You like to soak, don't you. But I would say in 25 years, probably 25 times. That's an average of once a year. Shawnee, what about you? I've gotten to Maddie Petty.
主要是脚。而且，因为她们会按摩你的脚。所以感觉很好。你喜欢泡脚，不是吗？但我会说在25年里，大概做了25次。那平均一年一次。肖尼，你呢？我做过美甲足疗。
The last one I got, she scrubbed my calves so hard. I broke out into hives after it was over. Huh. I'm definitely Eastern European. That's not a thing. No, that was on Larchmont. But it has nothing to do with her doing the calves. Yeah, it was terrible.
我上次做的时候，她用力擦我的小腿。结束后我起了一身荨麻疹。哈。我绝对是东欧人。那不是一回事。不，那是在拉奇蒙特。但这和她擦小腿没关系。是啊，太糟糕了。
Well, listen, thanks for the weird morning chat. Wait, wait, wait, hold on one second. I forgot I have something I need to say and announce. I'm going to be doing a show called the... Sorry, we're out of time. Great having you on the show. I'm best luck in whatever you're doing. We never got to it.
好了，听着，谢谢你们这奇怪的早晨聊天。等等，等等，等一下。我忘了我有件事需要说和宣布。我要做一个节目叫……抱歉，我们没时间了。很高兴你能来节目。祝你在做任何事情时都好运。我们从来没谈到那个。
All right. So this is a one act. Where is it, Williamstown? No. This is a show called The Unknown. It's a one-man play, which is now, I guess, people are calling them solos. It's written by David Kale, directed by Lee Silverman.
好吧。所以这是一部独角戏。是在哪里，威廉斯敦吗？不。这是一部叫《未知》的节目。这是一部单人剧，我想现在人们称之为独角戏。它由大卫·凯尔编写，李·西尔弗曼导演。
It's at Studio C-view in New York City for 10 weeks only. Tickets are in sale now at the Unknown Play.com. Wait, when does it start? January 31st. January 31st. May I just say publicly here. I've said to you privately. I just think it's so freaking admirable and badass
它将在纽约市的C-view工作室上演，为期10周。门票现在在UnknownPlay.com上发售。等等，什么时候开始？1月31日。1月31日。我能在这里公开说一下吗？我私下里已经对你说过了。我觉得这真是太令人钦佩和太酷了
that you raised your hand in. said yes to doing a one-man show is like, I mean, you know, seeing Krasinski do his thing and I, our buddy Billy Cruttup has done it, Laura Lee's out of the way, that's the same writer-director of that show. Yeah, I just, it's like what a monumental thing to take on. You convince me, I'll go see it. I just, I'm so, I just checking my schedule. I can't wait. Unknown. Who knows what will happen? I'm so proud of you, Shepard. I'm so proud of you, Thank you, thank you, thank you. Because it's very easy to just sit back and not do anything and just enjoy,
你举手说愿意做一部单人剧，我的意思是，你知道，看到克拉辛斯基做他的事情，还有我们的伙伴比利·克鲁德普也做过，劳拉·琳妮也做过，那是同一位编剧兼导演。是啊，我只是觉得这是一件多么宏大的事情。你说服我了，我会去看的。我只是在查看我的日程安排。我等不及了。未知。谁知道会发生什么？我为你感到骄傲，谢泼德。我为你感到骄傲，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。因为坐享其成什么都不做很容易，
but you're challenging yourself and it's rad. Thank you, thank you. I'm not going to come, but I do think that it will probably be good. All right. Well, thank you for that. Yeah. Who are you, and who are your co-stars? Yeah, so it's, that's my friend who listens a lot.
但你在挑战自己，这很棒。谢谢，谢谢。我不会去，但我确实认为它可能会很好。好吧。好吧，谢谢你。是啊。你是谁，你的联合主演是谁？是啊，那是我的朋友，他听得很多。
The Unknown Play.com, that's where you get your ticket. The Unknown Play.com, and it starts the end of January. Get your tickets now. I will be there with bells on. Thank you, thank you. Yep. Let's get to our guest. We're going to ask her what her hygiene routine is.
UnknownPlay.com，那是你买票的地方。UnknownPlay.com，它在一月底开始。现在就去买票吧。我会盛装出席的。谢谢，谢谢。是的。让我们请出我们的嘉宾。我们要问问她的卫生习惯是什么。
I'll bet it's significant because you know what? This is called self-care. It's not hygiene. It's self-care, by the way. Yeah, self-care. She's been impressing critics and audiences for over 30 years, you guys, achieving incredible success, yet finds herself even more relevant today than ever before. Okay, she's been awarded multiple Emmys, Golden Globes, Sags, all that crap.
我敢打赌这很重要，因为你知道吗？这叫自我护理。这不是卫生。顺便说一句，这是自我护理。是啊，自我护理。她已经让评论家和观众印象深刻超过30年了，伙计们，取得了令人难以置信的成功，但今天却发现自己比以往任何时候都更具影响力。好吧，她获得了多项艾美奖、金球奖、演员工会奖，所有那些东西。
And she's been named one of times most influential people in the world. Wow. That's something none of us can say. Never will now. She's Yale educated. Also, you can't say that. She's a proud mother of three. You can't say that.
而且她被评为《时代》杂志全球最具影响力人物之一。哇。这是我们任何人都无法说的。现在永远也不会了。她是耶鲁大学毕业的。而且，你不能那样说。她是三个孩子的骄傲母亲。你不能那样说。
And she's very kind to the women of Afghanistan. Can you guys say that? No. Guys, let's welcome Chris and Clara's girl, the one and only Claire Dane's. Come on now. Hi, guys. Oh, my gosh, I'm such a big fan. Right, I mean, she's everything.
而且她对阿富汗妇女非常友善。你们能那样说吗？不能。伙计们，让我们欢迎克里斯和克拉拉的女孩，独一无二的克莱尔·丹妮丝。来吧。嗨，伙计们。哦，天哪，我是她的超级粉丝。对吧，我的意思是，她就是一切。
Look at her. It's really nice to meet you. The gang. And you are. Yeah, you have all had more facials than I have, I think, ever. Is that true? Come on. Yeah.
看看她。很高兴见到你。伙计们。而你是。是啊，你们所有人都比我做过更多的面部护理，我想，从来没有。是真的吗？得了吧。是啊。
Really? Occasionally, like, I'm gifted a facial by, I don't know. Right. Like a start gift from an agent. Yes, something like that. And I'll go. A start gift. And I enjoy it, but I, yeah, I forget to.
真的吗？偶尔，比如，我被赠送了一次面部护理，我不知道。对。就像经纪人送的礼物。是的，类似的东西。我会去。一份礼物。我很享受，但我，是啊，我忘了去。
But I do get my nails done weekly. Yeah. Okay. Oh, you do. Because it's like my office. I get a lot of work done. I never do the fingers. I experimented with the gels for a little while, but that was quite stressful because I don't know.
但我确实每周做一次指甲。是啊。好的。哦，你做。因为那就像我的办公室。我能完成很多工作。我从来不做手指。我尝试过一段时间凝胶指甲，但这压力很大，因为我不知道。
And it's also a whole different look, right? I mean, I've got two daughters, and I'm starting to get educated on the gels versus let's have some discipline and let it grow out naturally. Yeah. I feel like it is a cultural statement to have gels on. It is, and you can't, you have to go back to get them off. So that is the hard part. That made me feel kind of panicked and claustrophobic. Or you can be on the volleyball team and then they just come off naturally.
而且这也是一种完全不同的外观，对吧？我的意思是，我有两个女儿，我开始了解凝胶指甲和让我们有纪律地让它自然生长之间的区别。是啊。我觉得做凝胶指甲是一种文化宣言。是的，而且你必须回去卸掉它们。所以那是困难的部分。这让我感到有点恐慌和幽闭恐惧。或者你可以参加排球队，然后它们就会自然脱落。
Right. Well, but I don't play enough volleyball. I like the way J.B. couches it in, oh, my daughter's helped educate me. Like, fucking bullshit. I know how you live, babe, baby. Nice to fucking try. My weekend gel sessions. How many times as you go, like, oh, well, my kids really, I'm like, no, you like it.
对。嗯，但我打排球不够多。我喜欢J.B.的说法，哦，我女儿帮我普及了知识。就像，他妈的胡扯。我知道你是怎么生活的，宝贝。真他妈想尝试一下。我的周末凝胶指甲课程。你多少次说，哦，好吧，我的孩子们真的，我心想，不，你喜欢它。
I like Chels. I used to drag my son, Cyrus, our eldest son, with me to the salon. And I got, he, at about five, he had had enough. But until then, and then I had to bribe him with, like, an iPad. No, no, but I just really enjoyed that experience of going with him. What about all fancy dancing? Does he get the feats and toes done? Very, very.
我喜欢凝胶指甲。我过去常拖着我的儿子赛勒斯，我们的大儿子，和我一起去沙龙。我大概，他在五岁左右时就受够了。但在那之前，我不得不拿iPad贿赂他。不，不，但我真的很享受和他一起去的经历。那所有的花哨舞蹈呢？他做脚趾护理吗？非常，非常。
occasionally. Yeah. You kind of keep your man tight, you know? Yeah. Or are you the kind of gal that likes their guy to have a little bit of, a little bit of dirt under the nails? It depends what kind of dirt. Yeah.
偶尔。是啊。你得保持你的男人整洁，你知道吗？是啊。还是你是那种喜欢男人指甲里有一点点污垢的女孩？这取决于是什么样的污垢。是啊。
If it's like cute upstate dirt, sure. Right. That's very cute dirt. Because some women, I'm not, you know, some women, they're kind of turned off by a guy that actually keeps himself very clean and very, I'm one of those guys. I would turn a woman off. I respect it. I understand thread count.
如果是那种可爱的郊区污垢，当然。对。那是很可爱的污垢。因为有些女人，我不是，你知道，有些女人，她们会被一个实际上保持自己非常干净的男人拒之门外，我就是那种男人。我会让女人反感。我尊重这一点。我了解床单支数。
I understand candles and syroats and things. No, I'm for it. But, yeah. I'm not like a man's man. No, no. That's a quote. You won't find me on a horse unless. Hang on a second.
我了解蜡烛和香氛之类的东西。不，我支持它。但是，是啊。我不是那种男子汉。不，不。那是一句名言。除非……等一下。
I'm emailing the smartless merch people right now. We've got a new hoodie coming out. I'm not a manman. Claire, where are we finding you? What part of the world? What side of the United States are you on right now? I live in New York City. Yes, so jealous.
我正在给Smartless的周边商品人员发邮件。我们有一款新连帽衫要出。我不是男子汉。克莱尔，我们在哪里找到你？世界的哪个部分？你现在在美国的哪一边？我住在纽约市。是的，太嫉妒了。
This looks like it could be a brownstone, too. It's a brownstone. We've been here not for very long. We've been here about a year because we had this oopsie-dazy third baby. Oh, she's going to love hearing that. You've got to be careful. Yeah, yeah.
这看起来也像是一栋褐砂石建筑。这是一栋褐砂石建筑。我们住在这里没多久。我们住在这里大约一年了，因为我们有了这个意外的第三个孩子。哦，她会喜欢听到这个的。你得小心点。是啊，是啊。
I'm not, yeah. I was so old when that's, happened. I was 44. How old is the baby? She's two now. Oh, cute. Wait, you got pregnant at 44? I sure did. Golly. Good for you, good for Hugh. I didn't think it was possible. I really didn't. Very rare. So, no, it was, I was terrified. But it all was okay. Can I use the term blessing? What a blessing. It was. Total blessing. How did you find having a surprise, as you said, a surprise blessing at that point. Well, you know, it was actually really interesting
我不是，是啊。发生这件事时我太老了。我44岁。孩子多大了？她现在两岁。哦，可爱。等等，你44岁怀孕了？我确实怀孕了。天哪。为你高兴，为休高兴。我没想到这是可能的。我真的没想到。非常罕见。所以，不，那是，我很害怕。但一切都还好。我能用“祝福”这个词吗？真是个祝福。确实是。作为一个惊喜，正如你所说，在那个时候得到一个惊喜的祝福，你感觉如何？嗯，你知道，这实际上非常有趣
because I did not foresee this at all. And it was weird. Suddenly I felt like a funny shame. Really? Like I was... People are going to know I make love. Yeah, like I was naughty. Like I had been caught, like, fornicating past the point I was meant to.
因为我根本没有预见到这一点。而且很奇怪。突然间我感到一种奇怪的羞耻感。真的吗？就像我……人们会知道我做爱。是啊，就像我很淘气。就像我被抓住了，就像，在我不该做的时候发生了性关系。
No, it was weird because I was... And it was, it was like I found an edge that I didn't, I hadn't been quite conscious of. Yeah. Like, there's a certain, like, I was going outside of the parameters a little bit. Right. And I, and I, and that was, that was, that was wild. How, what's the, what's the age spread with the, the kid right before it? Um, so Cyrus is 12.
不，这很奇怪，因为我……而且，就像我发现了一个我之前没有意识到的边缘。是啊。就像，有一种，就像，我稍微超出了参数。对。而且我，而且我，而且那是，那是，那是疯狂的。在那个孩子之前的那个孩子，年龄差距是多少？嗯，赛勒斯12岁。
He'll be 13 in December. Rowan, our second boy is seven. And then Shea, yeah, so there's about five years between each. But it's a trip. I mean, I have a teenager and a toddler. And this last one is a girl? A girl. Yeah.
他十二月就13岁了。罗恩，我们的第二个男孩七岁。然后是谢伊，是啊，所以每个孩子之间大约有五年的差距。但这真是一段旅程。我的意思是，我有一个青少年和一个蹒跚学步的孩子。最后一个是女孩？女孩。是啊。
Wow. Yeah, I know. I got really, really lucky. My God. Yeah, my OBGYN was like, you know you're having another boy. But no, turns out. You would have been pissed off. You definitely would have been pissed off.
哇。是啊，我知道。我真的很幸运。天哪。是啊，我的妇产科医生说，你知道你又要生个男孩了。但没有，结果。你会很生气的。你绝对会很生气的。
I would have been delighted. But I am more delighted that I, yeah. That she's pretty cool. And she loves a tutu. Oh, yeah. Who doesn't? Who doesn't? A two-two and a tattoo.
我会很高兴的。但我更高兴的是我，是啊。她很酷。而且她喜欢芭蕾舞短裙。哦，是啊。谁不喜欢呢？谁不喜欢呢？芭蕾舞短裙和纹身。
I am noticing that this five-year gap is very good. My eldest just left the house for college, and the fact that I've still got a 13-year-olds. I've got another five years of, like, before I get really, really depressed. Yeah. It's great. Instead of just usually that usual gap of, what, two, three years or something like that. Yeah, you get built in.
我注意到这五年的差距非常好。我的长子刚离家去上大学，而我还有一个13岁的孩子。我还有五年时间，在我真正变得非常非常沮丧之前。是啊。这太棒了。而不是通常那种两三年的差距。是啊，你是内置的。
I say I've got a five-year-old and an almost 17-year-old as of next week. Right. It's kind of a trip It's great It's amazing I have a five-year-old dog Yeah Sean with your daughter
我说我有一个五岁的孩子和一个下周就快17岁的孩子。对。这真是一段旅程。这太棒了。这太神奇了。我有一只五岁的狗。是啊，肖恩，和你女儿一起
You're going to be moving into a 3-3 pretty soon Let's be honest Do you take him to get pedicures too Do you have to bribe him with the iPad as well No I don't I don't go often enough Despite what I was asking Sean about his dog Oh is Sean's dog
你很快就要搬进3-3了，说实话。你也带他去做足疗吗？你也得用iPad贿赂他吗？不，我不，我不常去。尽管我一直在问肖恩关于他狗的事。哦，是肖恩的狗
Yeah exactly how often do you get Ricky's toes done Once a week Once a week Yeah once a week Yeah once a week you know and that's and that's a thing those those that nail grinder for a dog i like i don't know how they sit still for that well they well they you tie you tie their neck around the thing so they stay on the on the table what you know what are you doing the monster and then rickie gets up
是啊，确切地说，你多久给里奇做一次脚趾护理？一周一次。一周一次。是啊，一周一次。是啊，一周一次，你知道，那是，那是，那个狗用的指甲研磨机，我不知道它们怎么能坐着不动。好吧，它们，你把它们的脖子绑在那个东西上，这样它们就留在桌子上了，你知道你在做什么吗，怪物，然后里奇起来了
no i'm kidding uh great you're covering the letters from pita here we fucking go where to go no because he's a golden door so you have to brush him out every week and all this stuff you wash him he gets real dirty anyway who cares When's the last time you washed your own dog, Sean? When he was a puppy? Yeah. Years ago. Absolutely years ago.
不，我开玩笑的，呃，太棒了，你在这里报道来自PETA的信件，我们他妈的走吧，去哪里，不，因为他是金毛寻回犬，所以你必须每周给他梳毛，所有这些东西，你给他洗澡，他变得很脏，无论如何，谁在乎。你上次给自己洗狗是什么时候，肖恩？当他还是只小狗的时候？是啊。几年前。绝对是几年前。
One's the last time you walked your own dog? Every, almost every day. Liar. I swear to you, I love taking a lot of walking. You actually do live in an area with sidewalks and trees and front yards. I would walk dogs. I'd have a dog walking service. Sorry, Claire, they'll be right with you.
你上次遛自己的狗是什么时候？几乎，几乎每天。骗子。我向你发誓，我喜欢遛狗。你确实住在一个有人行道、树木和前院的区域。我会遛狗。我会有一个遛狗服务。抱歉，克莱尔，他们马上就来。
They'd be trying to work out. Yeah, what about dogs there in the city? You have a dog there in the city? I had a dog. I had a schnoodle for about 16 years. His name was Ouija, but he passed. And then we adopted a cat when we were filming a season of Homeland in Morocco, Harold Hamza, and he was a bit of a nightmare.
他们会试图锻炼。是啊，那里的狗怎么样？你在城里有狗吗？我有一只狗。我有一只雪纳瑞大约16年了。他的名字叫威基，但他去世了。然后我们在摩洛哥拍摄《国土安全》一季时收养了一只猫，哈罗德·哈姆扎，他有点像个噩梦。
He pissed on everything. Those Moroccan cats. Is he still with us or no? You know what? After a really rough five years of dealing with this, like, urine-soaked sofa, furniture. I had to re-home him, which was very stressful. I've done that. And not obvious.
他在所有东西上撒尿。那些摩洛哥猫。他还和我们在一起吗？你知道吗？在经历了五年非常艰难的处理这种尿湿的沙发、家具之后。我不得不把他重新安置，这压力很大。我做过。而且不明显。
But found this saint in Indiana, this woman who has a cat sanctuary. And then three months into that arrangement, which was actually ideal, we got, you know, weekly photos and reports and things. He died. Oh, like there was some clot. I don't know. I think he was funny. The whole thing was. Wild.
但在印第安纳州找到了这位圣人，这位有猫咪庇护所的女士。在那个安排进行了三个月后，这实际上很理想，我们得到了，你知道，每周的照片和报告之类的。他死了。哦，就像有血栓一样。我不知道。我想他很有趣。整个事情都是。疯狂的。
From the rough streets of Casablanca to a pretty cushy situation in Indiana. Yeah. Yeah. And then, so when Ouija died, we had Harold Hamza, and then we adopted another cat. Mary, as in, like, Christmas, our son Rowan named her that when he was like three in the middle of the summer. It was very confusing. And we said, why did you, why marry? Everybody thinks it's Mary, it's not.
从卡萨布兰卡的粗糙街道到印第安纳州相当舒适的环境。是啊。是啊。然后，当威基死后，我们有了哈罗德·哈姆扎，然后我们收养了另一只猫。玛丽，就像圣诞节一样，我们的儿子罗恩在他三岁时在夏天中间给她取了这个名字。这非常令人困惑。我们说，你为什么，为什么叫玛丽？每个人都以为是玛丽，其实不是。
He said, I just thought it was a good name for a cat. That's a great reason. Anyway. Wait, Claire, how do you and Jay, how do you guys know each other? Did you work together? We don't, really. I mean, we've had a conversation maybe, but. Right.
他说，我只是觉得这是猫的好名字。那是个很好的理由。无论如何。等等，克莱尔，你和杰伊，你们是怎么认识的？你们一起工作过吗？我们没有，真的。我的意思是，我们可能谈过话，但是。对。
It is sort of surprising because we've both been banging around in the same. things since we were kids. I know it's a little weird. You guys had a conversation where was the location, Jason, we'll be right with you. Jason, I'm not asking you. I'm asking you, I'm asking for, because I want to get the truth. I think we, like, had a conversation on the phone, and I don't even really know why, but we did.
这有点令人惊讶，因为我们从小就在同样的事情里混。我知道这有点奇怪。你们谈过话，地点在哪里，杰森，我们马上就来。杰森，我没问你。我在问你，我在问，因为我想知道真相。我想我们，就像，在电话里谈过话，我甚至不知道为什么，但我们确实谈过。
Were you surprised at how short he was? Sorry, go ahead. No, do you know what? I know how long ago it was because it was a, I think it was like the same day that my parents delivered my schnoodle to me. They went and picked him up in Kentucky. They live in L.A. I live in New York, but, you know,
你对他那么矮感到惊讶吗？抱歉，继续。不，你知道吗？我知道那是多久以前的事了，因为那是，我想那是和我父母把我的雪纳瑞送给我的同一天。他们去肯塔基州接他。他们住在洛杉矶。我住在纽约，但是，你知道，
and I was filming in L.A. and they delivered this tiny little animal to me in my hotel room in L.A. And I had just talked to you for, you know, curious reasons. It was a nice conversation. Where did you grow up? I grew up in New York. I grew up in Soho, yeah.
我当时在洛杉矶拍戏，他们把这个小动物送到了我在洛杉矶的酒店房间里。我刚和你谈过，你知道，出于好奇的原因。那是一次愉快的谈话。你在哪里长大的？我在纽约长大。我在苏活区长大，是啊。
Oh, in the city? In the city. Ergo, the name of your company, yes? Is that the address of the place you grew up in, Crosby? Crosby. Well, actually, okay, yes. I grew up on Crosby Street. My parents were artists, and they moved to Soho, you know, in the late 60s.
哦，在城里？在城里。因此，你公司的名字，是吗？那是你长大的地方的地址吗，克罗斯比？克罗斯比。嗯，实际上，好的，是的。我在克罗斯比街长大。我的父母是艺术家，他们搬到了苏活区，你知道，在60年代末。
And when it became, you know, because there were all these factory buildings that were closing down. And you actually had to legally prove that you were an artist to live there because there was this concerted effort to, you know, transform. And they're trying to retroact. now charge all these finance bros that have gone in there and bought these artist lofts for really yeah um anyway like you you now have to prove that you're an artist to maintain this sweet deal on those places oh i didn't yeah they're trying to get it through i don't think it all wow that's fascinating wait but then they went on to do different things and my dad was a he had been a photographer we still had a dark room in our loft my entire childhood a vestige of
当它变成，你知道，因为有所有这些正在关闭的工厂建筑。你实际上必须在法律上证明你是艺术家才能住在那里，因为当时有一项协同努力，你知道，去改造。他们现在试图追溯，现在向所有进入那里并购买这些艺术家阁楼的金融兄弟收费，真的，嗯，无论如何，就像你现在必须证明你是艺术家才能维持这些地方的甜蜜交易，哦，我没有，是啊，他们试图通过它，我不认为它全部，哇，这太迷人了，等等，但后来他们继续做不同的事情，我爸爸是一个，他曾经是一名摄影师，我们的阁楼里整个童年都有一个暗房，这是他作为摄影师时期的遗迹
from his time as a photographer, but he was a contractor and had a company called Overall Construction. And now my production company name is Overall Production. Oh, that's great. Yeah, and my mom
但他是一名承包商，有一家叫Overall Construction的公司。现在我的制作公司名字叫Overall Production。哦，那太棒了。是啊，我妈妈
ran a toddler school in our loft called Crosby Kids. Wow. So that was weird. Yeah. And then I started acting and got John jobs, which was very surprising.
在我们的阁楼里经营一所幼儿学校，叫克罗斯比孩子们。哇。所以那很奇怪。是啊。然后我开始演戏并得到了工作，这非常令人惊讶。
Yeah, how'd that start? What was the impetus for that? I always knew I wanted to act, and I danced as a kid, and occasionally dance companies would come to my class looking for young talent, and I would get hired, and I started, you know, performing every so often and these black box theaters in the Lower East Side to 12 people, and loved it. and then started taking acting classes, at least Drossburg, which is like down the street from me now, which is very funny. And how old were you? Same. Same. I did the same.
是啊，那是怎么开始的？推动力是什么？我一直知道我想演戏，我小时候跳舞，偶尔舞蹈团会来我的班级寻找年轻人才，我会被雇佣，我开始，你知道，每隔一段时间在下东区的这些黑匣子剧院为12个人表演，我很喜欢。然后开始上表演课，至少是德罗斯堡，现在就在我街下，这非常有趣。你当时多大？一样。一样。我也做了同样的事。
Oh, really? I was 10. But it was like on a Saturday, and most kids were there because there was either that or like tennis class, but I was just so invested in the experience, you know, like such an earnest Nelly about it. Yeah. And then there was a Performing Arts Junior High School called PPS, professional performing art school. It was its first year of its existence, and I went. And then I met
哦，真的吗？我10岁。但那是在周六，大多数孩子在那里是因为要么是那个，要么是网球课，但我对这种经历非常投入，你知道，像个对此非常认真的傻瓜。是啊。然后有一所表演艺术初中叫PPS，专业表演艺术学校。那是它存在的第一年，我去了。然后我遇到了
kids there who were professional performing people and, you know, discovered what a headshot was and what an agent was and how to, you know, get them. And actually, that dark room came in handy because the woman who was renting it out kind of swapped rent money for headshots. So she took my headshots. And then I had done some student films when I was a kid. And so, So I had like something to show an agent and, you know, my first job was law and order. You know, like every to New York. Yeah, that's cool. And how soon after that did you get what I'm a huge fan of, and I'm sorry, you get asked all the time about it, my so-called life.
那里的孩子，他们是专业的表演人员，你知道，发现了什么是头像，什么是经纪人，以及如何，你知道，得到它们。而且实际上，那个暗房派上了用场，因为租用它的女人用头像换取了租金。所以她拍了我的头像。然后我小时候拍过一些学生电影，所以，所以我有一些东西可以展示给经纪人，你知道，我的第一份工作是《法律与秩序》。你知道，就像每个去纽约的人一样。是啊，那很酷。在那之后多久你得到了我非常喜欢的，我很抱歉，你一直被问到它，我的所谓生活。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I used to watch all the time. Oh, that's so nice to hear. Yeah, I loved it. I loved it. Yeah, I was 13 when I did the pilot. Wow. And then it did not get picked up.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。我过去经常看。哦，听到这个真好。是啊，我很喜欢它。我很喜欢它。是啊，我拍试播集时13岁。哇。然后它没有被选中。
And I Yeah, I'd gone to public school My whole life But then they made a chunk of change And could afford to send myself to private school So I went to this fancy school called Dalton And then halfway through my freshman year They actually did pick up the show
然后我，我这辈子一直上公立学校，但后来他们赚了一笔钱，能负担得起送我去私立学校。所以我去了这所叫道尔顿的昂贵学校。然后在我大一学期过半时，他们确实选中了这个节目
And I went to make the rest of it in L.A. And stayed there for four years My parents followed me My brother is seven years older So he was already at college at this point So we were kind of available to have this adventure. And so were you working in correspondence with Dalton,
我去洛杉矶拍了剩下的部分。并在那里待了四年。我的父母跟着我。我哥哥大七岁，所以他当时已经在上大学了。所以我们有点可以进行这次冒险。所以你是在和道尔顿通信工作，
or did you enroll in a different school in LA? Yeah, for that first year. And then eventually I went to the Liseé Francaise in L'A. Oh, yeah, in Culver City? Barely there. Yes. On motor? Yeah.
还是你在洛杉矶注册了另一所学校？是啊，第一年。然后最终我去了洛杉矶的法国中学。哦，是啊，在卡尔弗城？几乎没去。是的。在汽车上？是啊。
You bet you. Yeah, I tried to get in there. They wouldn't have me. But yeah, like maybe went five days a year, but I was mostly like tutored from that point on sets. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. I remember my so-co life, it had a, it kind of had that,
你敢打赌。是啊，我试着进去。他们没要我。但，是啊，就像一年可能去了五天，但我大部分时间都是从那时起在片场接受辅导。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。我记得我的所谓生活，它有一种，它有点那种，
it was critically acclaimed, and so it was kind of like sputtered a little bit. It had to, it lived in this weird place where everybody loved it, but the network didn't know what to do. Yeah, I mean, I didn't, nobody really watched it while it was on, and we didn't even complete a full season. We didn't make it to the 22, you know, mark. Yeah. We got canceled.
它受到评论界的好评，所以它有点像有点喷溅。它必须，它生活在这个奇怪的地方，每个人都喜欢它，但网络不知道该怎么办。是啊，我的意思是，我没有，当它播出时没人真正看它，我们甚至没有完成完整的一季。我们没有达到22，你知道，那个标记。是啊。我们被取消了。
at 19 episodes. But then it had a pretty, you know, the people who did watch were devoted and passionate, and they made a ruckus. And then it got bought by other, it aired, like it was on MTV. It was on MTV. Yeah, it was on MTV.
在19集时。但后来它有了一个相当，你知道，看的人很忠诚和热情，他们制造了骚动。然后它被其他人买了，它播出了，就像它在MTV上一样。它在MTV上。是啊，它在MTV上。
And so it was, and then it found its audience kind of after the fact. Tom Preston picked that. Now, am I right that your mom was your manager during this period? Yeah, kind of, like, by default. I mean, she was, you know, I was a kid and she was with me all the time. And, yeah. When did I ask only because my parents were my manager as well, and it was, it was complicated. Was it, did you, did you disengage from that before it became to?
所以它是，然后它在事后找到了它的观众。汤姆·普雷斯顿选了那个。现在，我说的对吗，你妈妈在那期间是你的经纪人？是啊，有点，就像，默认情况下。我的意思是，她是，你知道，我还是个孩子，她一直和我在一起。而且，是啊。我什么时候问只是因为我的父母也是我的经纪人，而且，这很复杂。是吗，你在它变得之前就脱离了吗？
Yeah, it was, you know, it, that, it made sense for a period of, of time and then they made more sense to just be mom and daughter. Right. Yeah, it wasn't uncommon. Most kids said their parents, yeah, yeah. But then once they start, you know, you're paying them a percentage and then that's kind of weird and, yeah. It changes to your relationship with your parents.
是啊，你知道，它，那，在一段时间内是有意义的，然后他们更有意义地只是做妈妈和女儿。对。是啊，这并不罕见。大多数孩子说他们的父母，是啊，是啊。但一旦他们开始，你知道，你付给他们百分比，然后那有点奇怪，而且，是啊。它改变了你与父母的关系。
Yeah. I mean, by definition. You're the employer. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's super complicated. Hey, grab me a coffee real quick. Yeah.
是啊。我的意思是，根据定义。你是雇主。是啊。是啊。是啊，那超级复杂。嘿，快给我拿杯咖啡。是啊。
But I was very, I mean, we were all just so stunned by this. You know, nobody anticipated this at all. We were just, like, totally naive. And, you know, then they, weirdly, we moved to L.A. The day after those Northridge, that Northridge earthquake. Ninety-nine. Four. 94.
但我当时非常，我的意思是，我们都被这个惊呆了。你知道，没人预料到这一点。我们只是，就像，完全天真。而且，你知道，然后他们，奇怪的是，我们搬到了洛杉矶。在那些北岭，那个北岭地震之后的那天。九十九。四。94。
Sorry. And it was a wild way to parachute into our new reality there because everybody was just ashen and traumatized. Yeah, that must have been horrified. Like two days before you're set to leave, your bags are packed, you see on the news, oh, the place we're going just got shaking. Yeah. Yeah. And then it was a week of aftershocks.
抱歉。而且这是一种疯狂的方式跳伞进入我们在那里的新现实，因为每个人都像灰烬一样，受到创伤。是啊，那一定很恐怖。就像在你准备离开的前两天，你的行李打包好了，你在新闻上看到，哦，我们要去的地方刚刚震动了。是啊。是啊。然后是一周的余震。
So we landed. It was like, you know. Oh, my God. And it was like a very apt metaphor for what we were feeling already, you know. But, but yeah. So, and but then my parents really loved it. My mom went to grad school in her 50s. They came back to their art.
所以我们着陆了。就像，你知道。哦，天哪。而且这就像一个非常贴切的隐喻，形容我们当时已经感受到的，你知道。但是，但是是啊。所以，而且但后来我的父母真的很喜欢它。我妈妈在50多岁时上了研究生。他们回到了他们的艺术。
So she went to a school called Otis. Oh, yeah. My dad built like his and her studios in their backyard. and they're, you know, full circle. You just jarred my memory because my father was, my dad was also a photographer and he's...
所以她去了一所叫奥蒂斯的学校。哦，是啊。我爸爸在他们的后院建了像他和她的工作室。而且他们，你知道，圆满完成了。你刚才震动了我的记忆，因为我父亲是，我爸爸也是一名摄影师，而且他是……
Cue the tire screech. To take photos of all of us as kids all the time and blow the pictures up and put him up on the wall. And put him up on the wall. What are you going to go to? Zoom lens? What's going on?
提示轮胎尖叫声。一直给我们的孩子拍照，把照片放大，贴在墙上。并贴在墙上。你要去哪里？变焦镜头？怎么了？
And would you put those photos just above the sunshade in the car so he could just look at him when he's going down the highway? You got. Oh Wait, did he process his own photos, Sean? Yeah, so he had a dark room in the basement
你会把那些照片贴在车里的遮阳板上方，这样他在高速公路上行驶时就能看着它们吗？你做到了。哦，等等，他处理自己的照片吗，肖恩？是啊，他在地下室有一个暗房
And he would develop them there And then, you know, he would put him on the wall of the house And it was really cool but weird for them So did your dad do your photos and your head shots and all that? No, no, he didn't But no, I mean, he didn't really take many photos of people He likes a landscape. Oh, I see, I see, I see, I.
他会在那里冲洗它们，然后，你知道，他会把它们贴在房子的墙上。这真的很酷，但对他们来说很奇怪。所以你爸爸拍了你的照片和你的头像以及所有这些吗？不，不，他没有。但没有，我的意思是，他并没有真正拍很多人的照片。他喜欢风景。哦，我明白了，我明白了，我明白了，我。
I mean, he does take photos of us, of course, all the time, but that's not, yeah. People don't tend to populate his images. So, with, with, my, was your mom, your mom was a sculptor? Is it? No. My mom does, yeah, she was a textile designer initially, and now she does, she has a lot of etchings. She does do a lot of sculpture, and she paints, it's. But both being artists, where you just sort of, kind of, obviously it's in your blood,
我的意思是，他当然一直给我们拍照，但那不是，是啊。人们往往不会出现在他的图像中。所以，和，和，我的，你妈妈，你妈妈是雕塑家吗？是吗？不。我妈妈做，是啊，她最初是纺织设计师，现在她做，她有很多蚀刻画。她确实做很多雕塑，而且她画画，这是。但两人都是艺术家，你只是有点，有点，显然它在你的血液里，
but did you kind of think from a very, very early age that arts, is going to be your path? Because I think your brother's a lawyer. Is that right? Yeah. Yeah. So like where, how was it, was it kind of predetermined or no or no?
但你是否从非常非常小的时候就认为艺术，将是你的道路？因为我想你哥哥是律师。那是对的吗？是啊。是啊。所以就像哪里，它是怎么样的，它是预先确定的还是不，还是不？
Well, it was a pretty creative environment. That's for sure. Yeah. I mean, they had a lot of art materials everywhere. It was fun. We had, also, we had, even before the baby school, we had a trapeze and a trampoline and a swing. Wow.
嗯，这是一个非常有创意的环境。那是肯定的。是啊。我的意思是，他们到处都有很多艺术材料。这很有趣。我们有，而且，我们甚至在婴儿学校之前，我们就有秋千和蹦床和秋千。哇。
These dirty hippies. Yes, yeah. It was like that. Wow. And all of our furniture was like found off of the street and my dad collected these old signs. So it was funky. And they had fun tools.
这些肮脏的嬉皮士。是的，是啊。就像那样。哇。而且我们所有的家具都是从街上捡来的，我爸爸收集了这些旧标志。所以它很时髦。而且他们有有趣的工具。
They had a light box and, you know, I was at a very, at a very unfair advantage with my like school projects because we had a lot of. And your brother just said, screw it to all of that. I'm going into law. Yeah. I mean, he's creative. He was very athletic. He was, I don't know.
他们有一个灯箱，而且，你知道，我在我的学校项目中处于一个非常不公平的优势，因为我们有很多。而你哥哥只是说，去他妈的这一切。我要去学法律。是啊。我的意思是，他很有创造力。他非常运动。他，我不知道。
Yeah, it was, but then I did that show. I did that show, Finding Your Roots. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Uh-oh, what'd you find out? Well, many things. But my mom, my dad's mom, Claire, whom I'm named after, she died when he was nine. So there was very, very little information about her. I knew nothing about her.
是啊，它是，但后来我做了那个节目。我做了那个节目，《寻找你的根源》。哦，是啊，是啊，是啊。哦哦，你发现了什么？嗯，很多事情。但我妈妈，我爸爸的妈妈，克莱尔，我以她的名字命名，她在九岁时去世了。所以关于她的信息非常非常少。我一点也不了解她。
And people, of course, ask, you know, are there any people in the performing arts in your family? No, a lot of visual artists, a lot of academic. but not, you know, but it turns out she, um, she, uh, went to Northwestern. It must have been in like the 40s. So I'm, and West Western in Chicago? Yeah. Cool it. And got her, like, studied theater and wrote her master's on the role of dance and
而且人们，当然，问，你知道，你的家庭里有表演艺术方面的人吗？没有，很多视觉艺术家，很多学术界人士。但不是，你知道，但事实证明她，嗯，她，嗯，去了西北大学。那一定是在40年代左右。所以我，而且芝加哥的西西部？是啊。冷静点。并得到了她的，就像，学习戏剧并写了她的硕士论文，关于舞蹈在
Shakespearean drama and, and had directed plays and acted in them. And I had no clue. How about that? So it was in your DNA a little bit? Yeah. I was very moved by that. Did she like her time in Illinois? Yeah, I have no idea.
莎士比亚戏剧中的作用，而且导演过戏剧并出演过它们。我一点也不知道。那怎么样？所以它在你的DNA里有一点？是啊。我对此非常感动。她喜欢在伊利诺伊州的时光吗？是啊，我不知道。
I don't know anything beyond that. But, yeah. Anyway, I also had my ninth great-grandmother was hanged in Salem for being a witch. Wow. What is the big reveal. Is that true? Yes.
我不知道除此之外的任何事情。但是，是啊。无论如何，我的第九代曾祖母在塞勒姆因为是女巫而被绞死。哇。这是大揭秘。那是真的吗？是的。
What, your great-grandmother? You found this on the show. Yes. Well, how did they find them? that out. What are you doing? Through, like, legal documents. Through other witches. Through other witches. Yeah. Do it crystal ball, you idiot. Wow. Wow. Hanged. Hanged. Hanged. I know. I learned that word. I didn't know it
什么，你的曾祖母？你在节目上发现了这个。是的。好吧，他们是怎么发现的。那出来。你在做什么？通过，就像，法律文件。通过其他女巫。通过其他女巫。是啊。用水晶球，你这个白痴。哇。哇。绞死。绞死。绞死。我知道。我学会了那个词。我不知道它
before this. So wait. So did she practice witchcraft and all that? I mean, is that? No. No. Actually, she was, she was the oldest woman to be hanged. She was 72. She was a widow. and I think she was just, like, low-hanging fruit. Like, she was just an easy scapego. Yeah, how about that one, crossing the road? Yeah, yeah, I think maybe. I mean, who knows? But, yeah, like, there are reports
在这之前。所以等等。所以她练习巫术和所有这些吗？我的意思是，那是？不。不。实际上，她是，她是年纪最大的被绞死的人。她72岁。她是寡妇。而且我想她只是，就像，低垂的果实。就像，她只是一个容易的替罪羊。是啊，那个过马路的人怎么样？是啊，是啊，我想也许。我的意思是，谁知道呢？但是，是啊，就像，有报道
because she was, went to court and everything. But people accused her of, what was it? Of, like, cursing their cows. And then put it, like, and then the cows would rear on their hind legs, and she would penetrate people's dreams. Like, yeah, she didn't do that, I can tell you. What is it, what year is this, I wonder? A long time ago.
因为她，去了法庭等等。但人们指控她，那是什么？就像，诅咒他们的牛。然后放，就像，然后牛会用后腿站立，而她会渗透人们的梦境。就像，是啊，她没做过，我可以告诉你。这是什么，这是哪一年，我想知道？很久以前。
I don't, I don't know. Like, would it be the 1,500, 1600s, 1st, maybe 1700s, 18. No, it's late 18, 18, probably early 18. 1,800s in Salem. Yeah. North Carolina. No. No, Salem, Massachusetts.
我不知道，我不知道。就像，会是1500年，1600年，第一，也许1700年，18。不，是18世纪末，18，可能是18世纪初。1800年代在塞勒姆。是啊。北卡罗来纳。不。不。塞勒姆，马萨诸塞州。
There's a few different Salem's. Okay. All right. Yeah, I'm sure. But certainly. Between 1692 and May, 1692 and May, Oh, you got a Google machine? Yep.
有几个不同的塞勒姆。好的。好吧。是啊，我肯定。在1692年和5月之间，1692年和5月，哦，你有一台谷歌机器？是啊。
Is that right? I have access to Google. That's what it says. Wow. Okay, well, I was say off. More than 200 people were accused, it claims. That's it? Wow.
那是对的吗？我有权访问谷歌。这就是它说的。哇。好的，好吧，我会说关闭。超过200人被指控，它声称。就是这样？哇。
The Salem Witch trials. 30 people were found guilty, 30 were found guilty, 19 of whom were executed by hanging. Yeah. And your ancestor was one of them. Yeah. For cursing cows. Yeah, yeah. And dream penetration.
塞勒姆女巫审判。30人被判有罪，其中19人被处以绞刑。是的。而你的祖先就是其中之一。是的。因为诅咒奶牛。是的，是的。还有梦境渗透。
She had it coming. Guys, let's go around the corner. Everybody, your dream penetration. Go ahead. That sounds so gross. Accent on the second word, yeah. So marching through the canon of your career here, let's hit, let's go to 96. Let's go to Romeo and Juliet.
她罪有应得。伙计们，我们换个话题吧。各位，你们的梦境渗透。继续吧。那听起来太恶心了。重音在第二个词上，对。那么，回顾一下你的职业生涯，我们来看看96。我们来谈谈《罗密欧与朱丽叶》。
Oh, my gosh. The working with Baz Luhrman was like, what was that set like? It was, I remember when that film came. I was like, oh my God, like the production design and like this big swing on this classic and really like, was it nerve-wracking or exciting to be on something that was taking such a big swing
天哪。与巴兹·鲁赫曼合作是什么感觉？那片场是什么样的？我记得那部电影上映的时候。我当时想，天哪，那种制作设计，还有对这部经典作品的大胆改编，参与这样一部大胆创新的作品，是让人紧张还是兴奋？
and it was such a big project? Yeah, all of the above. It was a total dream. I loved it. It was intense. We filmed in Mexico City. And I haven't been since. I loved it.
而且那是一个如此巨大的项目？是的，以上皆是。这简直是个梦想。我爱死它了。那段经历很紧张。我们在墨西哥城拍摄。从那以后我就没再去过。我爱那个地方。
But it's like an unruly, you know, vibrating brilliant place. And, yeah, it was, the whole thing felt very charged and alive and scary and fun. And Baz was wonderful. And he was very clear about making this accessible and exciting for everybody the way Shakespeare, you know, also intended his work to be every once upon a time. Had you done some Shakespeare prior to that and have you done after? Um, no. I haven't. And I hadn't. There was like a month where I read everything in Iambic pentameter, you know, like the cereal boxes. But, but yeah, it was, no, it was, it was amazing.
但它就像一个难以驾驭、充满活力、辉煌的地方。而且，是的，整个过程感觉非常充实、生动、既可怕又有趣。巴兹非常棒。他非常清楚要让这部作品像莎士比亚当年创作时那样，让每个人都能理解并感到兴奋。在那之前你演过莎士比亚的作品吗？之后演过吗？嗯，没有。我没演过。在那之前也没有。有那么一个月，我读了所有用抑扬格五音步写的东西，你知道，就像读麦片盒上的字一样。但，但是的，这真的很棒。
So you said, so then I hear you, you're saying you did some research there for at least a month. I think I read a book on iambic pentamer. Right. Well, there's, there's my question. How diligent are you? What kind of actor are you? Are you the one that does a massive amount of research and you've got tons of notes in your script? I'm a little nerdy about it. But not every role asked that of you. I mean, I don't do it for the sake of it.
所以你说，我听到了，你是说你在那儿做了至少一个月的调研。我想我读了一本关于抑扬格五音步的书。对。好吧，这就是我的问题。你有多勤奋？你是什么样的演员？你是那种做大量调研、剧本上记满笔记的人吗？我在这方面有点书呆子气。但并非每个角色都要求你这样做。我的意思是，我不会为了做而做。
I do it if I actually need to learn something. Like right now I'm about to play a pediatric neurosurgeon. And so I'm like reading some books on. Yeah, you should know. Neurosurgery. I sat in on a brain surgery. No way. I want to know all about it.
只有在我确实需要学习某些东西时我才会这样做。比如现在，我正要扮演一名儿科神经外科医生。所以我正在读一些关于……的书。是的，你应该了解。神经外科。我旁听了一场脑部手术。不会吧。我想了解关于它的一切。
I wouldn't be able to do that. It was wild. Did you pass out? No, but the... I asked that because I heard about somebody recently who sat in on one of those... I think it happens a lot. Yeah. I think it happens a lot.
我可做不到。那太疯狂了。你晕倒了吗？没有，但是……我问这个是因为我最近听说有人旁听了其中一场……我想这种情况经常发生。是的。我想这种情况经常发生。
And the surgeon's assistant did say, like, you may think you're a badass, but if you have the thought, oh, I might faint, you're fainting, and we can't have that happen. So please let me know. Wow. The second you feel it. Yeah. And I don't know. There was like a half an hour where I was doing something.
外科医生的助手确实说过，你可能觉得自己是个硬汉，但如果你脑子里闪过“哦，我可能会晕倒”的念头，那你就会晕倒，我们可不能让那种事发生。所以请务必告诉我。哇。你感觉到晕眩的瞬间。是的。我不知道。有半个小时我一直在做一些……
some conscious breathing. Wait a minute. So you're standing there while the brain is open and they're working on the brain. Yeah, what was the moment that started to get you a little bit I might be starting to pass out here?
一些有意识的呼吸。等等。所以你站在那里，当大脑被打开，他们正在对大脑进行手术时。是的，那一刻是什么让你开始觉得“我可能要晕倒了”？
Was it lifting of the scalp? When the residents were prepping the head for the actual surgeon to come and do his work. But yeah, so they cut the scalp and they peel it back and they bore four holes into the skull. Yeah, and then there's like,
是剥离头皮的时候吗？当住院医生为外科医生准备头部，以便他进行手术时。但是的，他们切开头皮，把它翻过来，然后在头骨上钻了四个孔。是的，然后还有……
I think it's called the derm. There's a thin layer of skin that they have to suture. They suture the corners and then they hoik it up like a tent, and then you have the brain ready. Wow. But wait, what about the part where they take like a bone saw and they cut the piece of the scalp out? That's right.
我想那叫硬脑膜。有一层薄薄的皮肤他们必须缝合。他们缝合角落，然后像帐篷一样把它撑起来，然后大脑就露出来了。哇。等等，那他们用骨锯切掉那块头骨的部分呢？没错。
So they do the four holes and then they cut with a saw and then they lift it up. And the brain's exposed? Yes. Oh, my God. Yes. It was, I actually, I really, really understood in a different way that we are vehicles. Yes.
所以他们钻了四个孔，然后用锯子切开，再把它掀起来。大脑就暴露出来了？是的。天哪。是的。我真的，我以一种不同的方式理解了我们只是载体。是的。
We are cars. Yeah. And we are not our bodies. Like we experience ourselves and the world through our bodies. Just something carries your brain around. That was like a, that was a profound thing. Yeah. That, you know, to really know that on a different level.
我们是汽车。是的。我们不是我们的身体。我们通过身体来体验自我和世界。只是有什么东西载着你的大脑到处走。那是一个深刻的领悟。是的。你知道，在另一个层面上真正理解这一点。
So did the person that you watched was a success and all that? Yeah. She had a brain tumor and then she didn't. But it was a lot of tumor. It took a long time to. It would suction that out. But isn't it wild, like the kind of access we have? It was very embarrassing because they have something called a timeout
那你观察的那个人手术成功了吗？是的。她患有脑瘤，然后就没有了。但肿瘤很大。花了很长时间才把它吸出来。但这不是很疯狂吗，我们所拥有的这种接触机会？这非常尴尬，因为他们有一个叫“暂停”的环节，
where everybody in the room has to announce themselves and say why they're there. What? Really, just to make sure if he's cognizant. I'm Claire, I'll be playing. Yeah, I'll be playing you in a month. Wait a second. In the operating room, there's a let's go around and introduce ourselves.
房间里的每个人都必须自报家门，说明他们为什么在这里。什么？真的，只是为了确保他神志清醒。我是克莱尔，我将扮演……是的，我一个月后会扮演你。等等。在手术室里，还要来个自我介绍环节？
Just so everybody's accountable. They don't already know each other this team? They do. I think it's just a ritualistic thing just to kind of get everybody focused. And then they announce what the procedure is going to be and so everybody knows they're in the right world. Yeah, it's fast.
只是为了让每个人都负责任。这个团队之前不认识吗？他们认识。我想这只是一种仪式，为了让每个人都集中注意力。然后他们会宣布手术内容，这样每个人都知道他们处在正确的位置。是的，很快。
You've heard all those stories. It's not a big deal. It's just to, you know. You've heard all those stories about like they took out the wrong kidney or they took out the something wrong. It's because that's why they announce everything. So this is why we're here. This is what we're doing.
你听过所有那些故事。这没什么大不了的。这只是为了，你知道。你听过所有那些关于他们切错了肾或者切错了什么东西的故事。这就是为什么他们要宣布一切。所以这就是我们为什么在这里。这就是我们要做的。
This is who I am. This is what we're, yeah. Yeah. I mean, the people that do this, that surgeon. I know. And I have to say, like, our sets are so much more protected than, you know, look, I was vetted. You know, I had a badge and everything, but I wasn't anybody, but it felt relatively porous. Like, you know, on a set, the feeling is so, can be so serious, like we are actually saving.
这就是我是谁。这就是我们……是的。我的意思是，做这件事的人，那位外科医生。我知道。我必须说，我们的片场比那个受保护得多。你看，我经过了审查。你知道，我有徽章什么的，但我什么都不是，但感觉相对松散。就像，你知道，在片场，那种感觉非常严肃，就像我们真的在拯救……
It was much more serious than it was in the over. Claire, I went to an event recently, and it was a very sort of Hollywood event, and they had dogs and looking into the cars and stuff. And I'm like, motherfucker, nobody's coming for our stars. Right, right, it's so true Everybody's over it, yeah I was very humbled by it But yeah So in those kind of cases
这比在手术室里严肃多了。克莱尔，我最近去参加了一个活动，那是一个非常“好莱坞”的活动，他们有狗，还在检查汽车什么的。我当时想，妈的，没人会来找我们的明星。对，对，这太真实了。大家都习以为常了，是的。我对此感到非常谦卑。但是的，在那种情况下……
I will do Yeah, like for Homeland I had to figure out How to be a spy And got to go to Langley and meet those guys And also had to figure out What it was to be bipolar
我会做。是的，比如为了《国土安全》，我必须弄清楚如何成为一名间谍，并有机会去兰利见那些人。而且我还必须弄清楚患有双相情感障碍是什么感觉。
That was fascinating When I played Temple I had to learn about autism You know, so yes In some cases You have to do some homework But a nice little sitcom for you You know?
那太迷人了。当我扮演坦普尔时，我必须学习关于自闭症的知识。你知道，所以是的，在某些情况下，你必须做些功课。但为你准备一部不错的小情景喜剧呢？你知道？
Yes. I get a multi-cam and, you know, it's just... This is J.B.,'s dream, by the way. Sorry, Claire. He's just walking through his dream. J.B., what time do you roll into your parking spot on the sitcom? 10 a.m., right?
是的。我接了一部多机位剧，你知道，这只是……顺便说一句，这是J.B.的梦想。抱歉，克莱尔。他只是在走他的梦想之路。J.B.，你几点把车开进情景喜剧的停车位？早上10点，对吧？
Don't you... I mean, you have played, taken on voluntarily, a lot of very heavy parts, and you do them incredibly well. Does it ever get exhausting to be, believably, in a space of weight? 80ness 12 hours a day for years on end? It's hard when you're first figuring it out.
难道你……我的意思是，你自愿承担了很多非常沉重的角色，而且你完成得非常出色。长期处于那种沉重的空间里，每天12个小时，持续多年，会不会感到精疲力竭？刚开始摸索的时候很难。
Right. You know, and once you are sort of oriented within the character and you've kind of made sense of her, it gets a little easier. It was very cool on Homeland to play somebody for so very long. Yeah. You know, like, you had kind of played your backstory. You lived your backstory. Right.
对。你知道，一旦你适应了角色，理解了她，就会变得容易一些。在《国土安全》里长期扮演一个人真的很酷。是的。你知道，你已经演完了你的背景故事。你活出了你的背景故事。对。
And you know the act. that you're working with so very well, you know, like it was just, that was amazing to have that fluency and that, and that juice, you know? Yeah, finding the momentum is always the toughest part. And, but I have to say, like, if the writing is good, it holds you, it carries you. Like, doing a kind of technically easy scene, but with bad writing. is so much harder than doing an exacting scene that is really well constructed.
而且你非常了解与你合作的演员，你知道，那种流畅感和那种动力真是太棒了，你知道吗？是的，找到节奏总是最难的部分。但我必须说，如果剧本写得好，它会支撑你，带动你。比如，演一场技术上容易但剧本很烂的戏，比演一场要求极高但结构精良的戏要难得多。
And with a team that can actually support you. You guys were together for how long on that show, eight years? It felt like, I think it was like, we did eight seasons, but it was about a decade in total. And you and the great Damien Lewis, too, right? I love that guy. Yeah. I don't know.
而且要有一个能真正支持你的团队。你们在那部剧里待了多久，八年？感觉像是，我想大概是八季，但总共大约十年。还有伟大的达米安·路易斯，对吧？我爱那个家伙。是的。我不知道。
I'm just talking a fan. And what about the travel on that? Did that, was that nice to visit those corners of the world? way that I'm imagining you were traveled and looked after? It was. It was nice, but I was also I'd like just gotten married when we started
我只是个粉丝。那旅行呢？去世界各地那些角落旅行感觉好吗？像我想象中那样，你旅行时有人照顾吗？是的。很好，但我也……我们开始拍那部剧时我刚结婚。
the show. I had Cyrus in my second season and then I had Rowan, I guess a few seasons late. I guess I had Rowan in our penultimate season. So like making a family while globe trotting in that way
我在第二季生了赛勒斯，然后我想几季后生了罗恩。我想我在倒数第二季生了罗恩。所以，以那种方式环游世界的同时建立家庭，
was challenging. And Cyrus, you know, grew up and all over the place. Like, he was a toddler in Cape Town. He went to kindergarten in Berlin. He went to school in Casablanca and can't eat cuss-cus to this day because he had it every day, you know, at lunch.
是很有挑战性的。赛勒斯，你知道，在各地长大。他在开普敦时是个蹒跚学步的孩子。他在柏林上了幼儿园。他在卡萨布兰卡上了学，至今都不能吃古斯古斯，因为他午餐天天吃那个，你知道。
You know, like when he was a little guy in a playground here in the city, you know, come up to people, his little other kids and say, you know, my name is Cyrus. I speak English. English. It was just not a given that they did. I had a mom who was a flight attendant for Pan Am and so we did a bunch of traveling. And as a consequence, I don't like to travel
你知道，当他还是个小家伙在城里的操场上时，你知道，会走到别人，其他小孩子面前说，你知道，我叫赛勒斯。我会说英语。英语。他们会说英语并不是理所当然的。我有一个当泛美航空空姐的妈妈，所以我们做了很多旅行。结果，我不喜欢旅行，
because I did it at an age where it was just inconvenient because I was so small and I missed my friends. What is his relationship with travel nowadays? Well, now, well, then Homeland ended and it was very like careful what you wish for because of course I was desperate to just be anchored at home and then I never got to leave the home like immediately we wrapped and then we were you know in the COVID era. That was a trip. And now and now we're working really hard to figure out how to remain employed and local. Yeah. It used to be like script, director, actor and now it's location, location, location. That's how you decide what you do. Kind of. I mean, I'm sort of making a joke, but basically for the next 10 years, we just have to, you know, find jobs
因为我在一个很不方便的年纪做了这些，因为我太小了，而且我想念我的朋友。他现在和旅行的关系如何？嗯，现在，嗯，后来《国土安全》结束了，这就像是“小心你所祈求的”，因为我当然渴望能扎根在家，然后我就再也没能离开家，我们刚拍完，然后我们就处于新冠时代了。那真是一段旅程。现在我们正在努力想办法如何在本地保持就业。是的。过去是剧本、导演、演员，现在是地点、地点、地点。这就是你决定做什么的方式。算是吧。我的意思是，我是在开玩笑，但基本上未来10年，我们只需要，你知道，在附近找工作。
in the neighborhood. What about going back to some of your theater stuff doing that? I mean, I know it doesn't pay the bills as well, but imagine you guys are all right. Yeah, I mean, I would definitely be open to that. But, yeah, lately it's been limited series in Westchester. I'm a little two-hander with the Tony Award-winning Sean Hange. Yeah, I love this. I love this casting.
回到你的一些戏剧作品怎么样？我的意思是，我知道那赚不了多少钱，但想象一下你们都还好。是的，我的意思是，我绝对会对此持开放态度。但，是的，最近都是在威彻斯特拍迷你剧。我和托尼奖得主肖恩·海耶斯演个双人戏。是的，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个选角。
Jason, keep going. What is it? It's a two-hander, you and Sean Hayes. Okay. This is a new take on the odd couple. I love it so much. We're going to switch roles every four weeks. We'll be right back.
杰森，继续。是什么？这是一个双人戏，你和肖恩·海耶斯。好的。这是对《单身公寓》的新诠释。我太喜欢了。我们每四周换一次角色。我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show. But you know what, Jason's right. You would be good at comp. I saw you in Portlandia, because I was a huge fan of that show. You were so, you played like... Oh, that's right, I forgot I did that. Yeah, you played like an acting coach or acting teacher or something. I did. I played a terrible acting coach.
现在，回到节目。但你知道吗，杰森是对的。你很擅长喜剧。我在《波特兰迪亚》里看过你，因为我是那部剧的超级粉丝。你演得太……哦，对了，我忘了我演过那个。是的，你演了一个表演教练还是表演老师什么的。我演了。我演了一个糟糕的表演教练。
Yeah, I remember that. A wildly pretentious acting coach. That was really funny. Oh, that's so sweet. Thank you. Fred Armisen. He's great. This guy, this guy, this guy's royalty.
是的，我记得那个。一个极其做作的表演教练。那真的很有趣。哦，太贴心了。谢谢。弗雷德·阿米森。他很棒。这家伙，这家伙，这家伙是王牌。
And I hear he's just put out an album I hear of sound effects. Amazing. That's it. Sounds about right. Yes, check and check. Yeah. That's funny. I love, I love Freddie.
我听说他刚出了一张音效专辑。太棒了。就是这样。听起来很对。是的，确认再确认。是的。那很有趣。我爱，我爱弗雷迪。
We're leaving Baz Luhrmann and we're moving on to Francis Ford Coppola with The Rainmaker. Wow. Let's talk about, did we? Well, can I just say something about Romeo and Julia before we get off of it? So you do that, and it has such a huge impact. And by the way, lasting impact. That film, it must have been a bit of a life changer. I mean, you'd already sort of made a lot of waves with my so-called life in that area.
我们要离开巴兹·鲁赫曼，转向弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉的《造雨人》。哇。让我们谈谈，我们谈过吗？好吧，在我们离开之前，我能说点关于《罗密欧与朱丽叶》的事吗？所以你演了那部戏，它产生了巨大的影响。顺便说一句，是持久的影响。那部电影一定改变了你的人生。我的意思是，你已经在《我所谓的生活》中引起了很大轰动。
And then you do this. And Romeo and Juliet just must have changed everything. You're much more visible. You must have felt that, like your life. Yeah, I did feel it. And I have to say, I didn't quite know what to do with all of that. I was a little thrown by it. Were you?
然后你做了这个。而《罗密欧与朱丽叶》一定改变了一切。你更引人注目了。你一定感觉到了，就像你的生活。是的，我感觉到了。我必须说，我不太知道该怎么处理这一切。我被它弄得有点不知所措。是吗？
Yeah, yeah. What was the big jarring thing? Was it the press? Was it people stopping on the street? Yeah, it was kind of the attention. It was a different kind of attention. Yeah. And I just, you know, didn't know how to focus.
是的，是的。最让人不安的是什么？是媒体吗？是人们在街上拦住你吗？是的，是那种关注。那是另一种关注。是的。我只是，你知道，不知道该如何集中精力。
like what how to how to work with it or where to direct it or I was a tiny human still right and then it's like oh look who's getting coffee at coffee bean and tea leaf type stuff right like yeah I just thought oh god like I don't know I I it it made me anxious you're sharing yourself with with a whole world yeah yeah and I thought I was supposed to know how to be like a movie star and really didn't and and and And now I realized, oh, don't worry about it. It's not really a thing. What did you do about that? I think I read that you're a friend of therapy like all of us. Sure. Was that helpful? Yes.
就像如何，如何处理它，或者把它引向何处，我当时还是个小人儿，对吧？然后就像，哦，看谁在咖啡豆和茶叶店买咖啡之类的，对吧？是的，我只是想，哦天哪，我不知道，我，它让我焦虑。你和全世界分享你自己。是的，是的，我以为我应该知道怎么做一个电影明星，但实际上我根本不知道，而且，而且，现在我意识到，哦，别担心。那根本不算什么。你对此做了什么？我想我读到过你像我们所有人一样是心理治疗的拥护者。当然。那有帮助吗？是的。
Yes. I've been in therapy since I was six. I'm a New Yorker. Right, right. And it's a great resource. If you have a great therapist, it can be very... Have you been with the same therapist the whole time? Dangerous, if it's not.
是的。我从六岁起就开始接受心理治疗了。我是个纽约人。对，对。这是一个很好的资源。如果你有一个很棒的治疗师，它可以非常……你一直用同一个治疗师吗？如果不是的话很危险。
Since I was about 18, yeah. No way. Oh, wow, that's great. I'm going right after this, actually. go in and out. Like, I take very substantial breaks. But I'm back in now, and I'm glad of it. Have you ever lied to this therapist?
从我大约18岁开始，是的。不会吧。哦，哇，那太棒了。其实我做完这个就要去了。进进出出。就像，我休息了很长时间。但我现在又开始了，我很高兴。你对这个治疗师撒过谎吗？
Maybe by omission. I don't think I've ever explicitly lied. Oh, I just forgot to mention that. But, yeah, there's sometimes... Claire, I asked Sean once. Sean, remember I asked you if I ever came up in your therapy. Yeah, everybody does. Everybody in your whole life does.
也许是隐瞒了一些。我不认为我明确撒过谎。哦，我只是忘了提那个。但，是的，有时……克莱尔，我曾经问过肖恩。肖恩，记得我问过你我是否在你的治疗中出现过吗？是的，每个人都会。你生命中的每个人都会。
How do I do, Sean? Yeah, well, it's private. It's confidential. Private, dude. Yeah, what are you doing? I'll call your therapist. You're in touch with his therapist. I owe him a call.
我表现如何，肖恩？是的，嗯，这是私人的。这是保密的。私人，伙计。是的，你在干什么？我会给你的治疗师打电话。你和他的治疗师有联系。我欠他一个电话。
Hi, Nikki, Jason. Did I guess right? Is it a man or a woman? Me? It's a woman. All right. Yeah, yeah. Nikki Glazer.
嗨，尼基，杰森。我猜对了吗？是男的还是女的？我？是个女的。好的。是的，是的。尼基·格雷泽。
Nicky Glazer. Unbelievable. Yeah, we got it all sorted out. I think she'd be an amazing thing. She would be. All right, let's do Francis Ford Coppola. Then I want to get to Stephen Daldry. Okay.
尼基·格雷泽。难以置信。是的，我们都搞定了。我想她会是一个了不起的人。她会的。好的，让我们谈谈弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉。然后我想谈谈斯蒂芬·戴德利。好的。
You know, I do like these directors. I mean, you've been in some great, great movies. You've worked with so many great actors and directors. I mean, golly, what do you think is the most impactful thing you've absorbed, learned from any of these actors? You don't even need to say which one it is. What do you think has been... Yeah, what changed your life and how it applies either to you in life or professionally?
你知道，我确实喜欢这些导演。我的意思是，你演过一些非常非常棒的电影。你和这么多伟大的演员和导演合作过。我的天，你认为你从这些演员身上吸收、学到的最有影响力的东西是什么？你甚至不需要说出是谁。你认为那是什么……是的，什么改变了你的生活，以及它如何应用在你的人生或职业生涯中？
Okay, okay, here's the story. So my first audition ever, I was 12. It was, again, in some theater, not, like, Lowery Side kind of situation. And I don't know what's happening. And there's a guy, like, having his audition, I can only hear him. But he's like, it sounds like an exorcism is happening. It's like he's thrashing about, you know. And he comes in and he's like stripping with sweat and he's just like vibrating this manic energy.
好的，好的，这是个故事。我第一次试镜时，我12岁。那是在某个剧院，不是那种下东区的环境。我不知道发生了什么。有个家伙在试镜，我只能听到他的声音。但他听起来就像在进行驱魔。他好像在挣扎，你知道。他进来时汗流浃背，浑身散发着狂躁的能量。
And it was Philip Seymour Hoffman. Wow. But I was like, holy shit, what's supposed to happen in there? What am I supposed to be? What am I following? Like, what am I walking into? What do they expect of me? I loved the meeting for the kid that same day.
那是菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼。哇。但我当时想，天哪，里面应该发生什么？我应该是什么样？我该追随什么？我走进了一个什么地方？他们对我有什么期望？那天我确实得到了那个孩子的角色。
Yeah. Yeah. But, yeah, so I don't know. I mean, I didn't know how, I mean, I sort of knew how extraordinary. these people were when I first started, but not like I do now. I don't know how wildly rare and absurd it is to get to collaborate with people of that genius.
是的。是的。但，是的，所以我不知道。我的意思是，我不知道如何……我的意思是，我刚开始时确实知道这些人有多非凡，但不像现在这样。我不知道能与那种天才合作是多么罕见和荒谬。
Have you noticed that, you know, like from, let's say, Merrill Street to Leonardo DiCaprio, like, is there, there are so many different ways to go about doing what it is that, we do some as we were talking about earlier some are very very specific and and surgical about it and very prep oriented and others just sort of just kind of wing it and keep it all natural and and the performances are equally great is that has that been a bit of a of an eye opener for you okay so the thing i remember about francis is that he you know he kind of asked a lot of you but it was all in a
你有没有注意到，你知道，比如从梅丽尔·斯特里普到莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，有很多不同的方式来做我们所做的事。正如我们之前谈到的，有些人非常非常具体和外科手术式，非常注重准备，而另一些人只是随性而为，保持自然，表演同样出色。这对你来说是一个开眼界的时刻吗？好的，关于弗朗西斯，我记得的是，他确实对你要求很高，但这一切都是在一种……
playful spirit so he he gave everybody the homework assignment of writing, you know, six pages of backstory for their care, you know, okay. And, and I remember there was a scene where I was meant to be very distressed and crying and the big, and I sat on the chair and it was actually like a block of ice. That was, you know, and that, he thought might help elicit some, you know, some feeling. He had a teamster scream at me. Oh, jeez. And I kind of was like, okay, I didn't need it.
顽皮的精神中进行的。所以他给每个人布置了家庭作业，写六页关于他们角色的背景故事，你知道，好的。我记得有一场戏，我应该非常痛苦并哭泣，我坐在椅子上，那实际上像一块冰。那是，你知道，他认为这可能有助于激发一些感觉。他让一个场务对我大喊大叫。哦，天哪。我当时想，好吧，我不需要那个。
How old were you? I was 17, I guess. But actually I was very touched that he just cared that much, like that he was invested, that he felt present with me, that he was committed to creating something special with me. Like that was the thing that actually got to the feeling was that I don't know, and I remember on that set it was something
你当时多大？我想我17岁。但实际上我非常感动，因为他那么在乎，他投入其中，他和我在一起，他致力于和我一起创造一些特别的东西。那才是真正触动我感觉的东西，我不知道，我记得在那个片场，发生了一些……
kind of magical that happened and ineffable like suddenly you landed on that set and you were held by it like you knew you were oriented you felt grounded in whatever reality you meant to be in in the place and that was his doing
某种神奇且难以言表的事情，突然你降落在那个片场，你被它所包容，就像你知道你被引导了，你感到扎根于你本应在的任何现实中，那是他的功劳。
but I don't know how he did it exactly and the same is true of Baz a totally different approach he did not have teamsters yell at me and actually it was almost surgical the way in which he directed. I mean, he knew exactly. It was very prescriptive, but...
但我不知道他到底是怎么做到的。巴兹也是如此，完全不同的方法。他没有让场务对我大喊大叫，实际上他导演的方式几乎是外科手术式的。我的意思是，他非常清楚。这非常规范，但是……
Was it result-oriented? No. Like, he just was very... It's so, so detail-oriented. You know, and he builds the world, and it's really ornate, and it's hyper-considered and stylized. But he wants a free-feeling performance from his actors,
这是结果导向的吗？不。他只是非常……非常注重细节。你知道，他构建了那个世界，它非常华丽，经过深思熟虑且风格化。但他想要演员们表现出一种自由的感觉，
And that's why it's often exciting the word because it's that contrast. Right. So it creates a sort of a, yeah. But yeah, I mean, and I have to say there are a lot of directors, too, not these guys. These guys are brilliant. But I think I'm always surprised by the number of directors that are actually really terrified of conflict and visceral feeling. They would rather you not. You know, and they don't even know that they're guiding you a way, like,
这就是为什么工作通常很令人兴奋，因为那种对比。对。所以它创造了一种……是的。但，是的，我必须说，也有很多导演，不是这些人。这些人是天才。但我认为我总是对那些实际上非常害怕冲突和本能感受的导演的数量感到惊讶。他们宁愿你不要那样。你知道，他们甚至不知道他们在引导你远离，就像，
they want you to make choices that's going to take you further from actual expressive feeling, you know? Oh, interesting. Too real. And, you know, and you're like, but why are you doing this? And I'm, well, because you want to be at a move from it. Like, you want to, you know, so those directors, too. It's too good. Too real.
他们希望你做出让你远离真实表达感受的选择，你知道？哦，有趣。太真实了。而且，你知道，你会想，但你为什么要这样做？我，嗯，因为你想从中走出来。就像，你想，你知道，所以那些导演也……太好了。太真实了。
Sean, you used to pay a guy to yell at you, right? Yeah. You put an ad in Craigslist or something. I still do, yeah. I still do. You sit yourself on a block of ice, too. Yeah, yeah. But I think even, you know, the privilege of working with people like Merrill and Leah, like, is, yeah, they're insanely gifted and they're, you know, and capable.
肖恩，你以前付钱让人对你大喊大叫，对吧？是的。你在Craigslist上登了广告什么的。我现在还在做，是的。我还在做。你也坐在冰块上。是的，是的。但我认为即使是，你知道，与梅丽尔和莱昂纳多这样的人合作的特权，就像，是的，他们非常有天赋，而且他们，你知道，有能力。
But they're also, you know, figuring it out, you know, like, nobody gets to just like, you never get to a point where you're actually confident. I mean, so, but you're never phoning it in. Like, ever. Yeah, I know that you're producing a lot of the stuff that you do as well now. And what about, did you ever get behind the camera on Homeland? No. Any desire? No.
但他们也，你知道，在摸索，你知道，没有人能仅仅……你永远不会达到一个你真正自信的程度。我的意思是，但你永远不会敷衍了事。就像，永远不会。是的，我知道你现在也制作很多你参与的作品。你在《国土安全》时有没有尝试过幕后工作？没有。有任何渴望吗？没有。
None really. I mean, I kind of, if I had the time, I would like to shadow a director just so that I could learn more about the parts of the process that we don't have access to because I'm curious. But not with the intent of really doing it myself. I am enjoying producing. I like, you know, being part of the conversation, like those consequential conversations about what it's going to be in its entirety.
真的没有。我的意思是，如果我有时间，我愿意跟随一位导演，这样我就能更多地了解我们无法接触到的过程部分，因为我很好奇。但不是为了真正自己去做的意图。我很享受制作。我喜欢，你知道，参与对话，就像那些关于它整体将是什么样的重要对话。
Right. But, yeah, I don't, directing seems really hard. Yeah. You're going to put it. Yeah, yeah, it does. So, Claire, you know, aside from, I love what you said now, it used to be script director, blah,
对。但，是的，我没有，导演看起来真的很难。是的。你要把它……是的，是的，确实。所以，克莱尔，你知道，除了，我喜欢你刚才说的，过去是剧本、导演、演员，
and now it's location, location, location. I love that. That's so interesting and true, and I get it. But how does that, so that factors in with your days consist of momming and parenting and being home with the kids, yeah, and making sure everything's taking care of with your husband? When you're not working, right? When you're not working? When you're not working?
现在是地点、地点、地点。我喜欢那个。这太有趣且真实了，我明白了。但这怎么……这是否与你每天的妈妈生活、育儿、和孩子们待在家里，是的，并确保和你丈夫一起照顾好一切有关？当你没工作的时候，对吧？当你没工作的时候？当你没工作的时候？
Yeah, you try to just bank the hours. Yeah, so did you get any time during the day when you're not working to do something for you? Yes, for sure. Shides of any petty? Yeah. I like the yoga. Yeah? I like a little hot yoga.
是的，你试着存点时间。是的，所以当你没工作时，白天有时间为你自己做点什么吗？是的，当然。做点什么？是的。我喜欢瑜伽。是吗？我喜欢热瑜伽。
Uh-huh. Yeah, I have, like, lunch with my friends. Good, good, good, good. Sure. Book club. Oh, really? Yeah. Wait, so you go to yoga and then you read a book.
嗯哼。是的，我和朋友吃午饭。好，好，好，好。当然。读书俱乐部。哦，真的吗？是的。等等，所以你去练瑜伽，然后读一本书。
I mean, God damn. I wish I was like that. It sounds like, doesn't Giamani? Didn't Paul say that that's how his day is kind of like that? Yeah, I think so. Yeah. Do you live with Paul Giumani? Yes.
我的天哪。我希望我也能那样。听起来，吉亚玛尼不是吗？保罗不是说他的日子就是那样的吗？是的，我想是这样。是的。你和保罗·吉亚玛尼住在一起吗？是的。
Hot yoga. It just sounds so masochistic. No, you can't do it. Well, it's, first of all, yoga itself, you just, you're sweating. because you're stretching is just sort of like being trapped in a hot car in a tortuous
热瑜伽。听起来太受虐了。不，你做不到。好吧，首先，瑜伽本身，你只是，你在出汗。因为你在拉伸，就像被困在炎热的车里，在折磨中……
but then to actually we're going to go ahead and we're going to preheat the car it just seems like what fuck you Jason it's your nightmare it's sweaty and the smell of the unwashed
但还要预热车子，这看起来就像……去你的，杰森，这是你的噩梦，又热又臭，还有没洗澡的味道。
and then getting sweatier and then guess what and then you've got to walk across the floor when you're done to get to your shoes outside
然后变得更热，然后猜猜怎么着，当你做完后，你还得走过地板去拿外面的鞋子。
and you're splashing through the fucking puddles of these. So you sound like you really know it. Oh, dude. You've done this. I knew it. And I was like, I'm good. That'll do it. It was just one class for you?
然后你踩过这些该死的积水。所以听起来你真的很了解。哦，伙计。你做过这个。我就知道。我当时想，我很好。这就够了。对你来说只是一节课？
It was maybe one and a half, something like that. Yeah, I just, if I'm going to sweat, I want to be active. I don't want to be holding a pose and feeling my pores open while I'm still. Wow. It really hit hard. I want to get to, one. This trailer for The Beast and Me rocked my world. I watched it three times in a row.
可能是一节半，差不多吧。是的，我只是，如果我要出汗，我想保持活跃。我不想保持一个姿势，在静止时感受毛孔张开。哇。这真的很深刻。我想谈谈，第一。这个《野兽与我》的预告片震撼了我的世界。我连续看了三遍。
I cannot wait to see the show, which is out now. November 13th, it launched. I'm assuming it's doing very, very well. But this looks like you got that pain in the ass, Matthew Reese. But besides that, it seems like. Such a pain. Oh, my God. It seems like.
我迫不及待想看这部剧，现在已经播出了。11月13日上线。我假设它表现得非常好。但这看起来你遇到了那个讨厌鬼马修·瑞斯。但除此之外，它看起来……真是个麻烦。哦，天哪。它看起来……
The shame of whales. and just and talent free I don't get it I know never got it with Reese he's a little wooden but you know I'm gonna text him
鲸鱼的羞耻。而且毫无天赋，我不明白。我知道，瑞斯那个人从来都不行，他有点木讷，但你知道，我会给他发短信。
you know he has a charisma that you know it looks so so good I can't wait to see you two go at it is it as good as it seems it's got to be yeah I think it's good I think it's fun
你知道他有一种魅力，你知道，看起来太棒了，我迫不及待想看你们两个交锋。有看起来那么好吗？一定是的。是的，我想很好，我想很有趣。
it's a yeah I had a blast making it where was that shot that looks like isn't a tasting New Jersey New Jersey Who do you play in it? Because it's about like a guy who's a murder or something or, right?
这是一个……是的，我拍得很开心。那是在哪里拍的？看起来不像是在新泽西吗？新泽西。你在里面演谁？因为它是关于一个谋杀犯什么的，对吧？
She's a writer. I'm a writer. Yes, a pretty successful writer. And I, you know, one, the Pulitzer was kind of cresting in my, you know, success. And my wife and I and our small boy moved to a pretty affluent suburb been on Long Island. And then tragedy strikes, I'm driving the car with our six-year-old son in the back and we get hit by a drunk driver and my world is ended.
她是作家。我是个作家。是的，一个相当成功的作家。而且我，你知道，普利策奖在我的成功中处于巅峰。我和我妻子还有我们的小男孩搬到了长岛一个相当富裕的郊区。然后悲剧发生了，我开车带着我们六岁的儿子在后座，我们被一个酒驾司机撞了，我的世界毁灭了。
The marriage dissolves, falls apart, and I am kind of creatively paralyzed. I can't produce any work and am rattling around in this, you know, gorgeous, but, neglected home needs a lot of work and suddenly I can't afford to pay for it. And suddenly this man moves in next door, who's a pretty controversial figure, like a real estate sion and, you know, very famous, very moneyed and, you know, and a little problematic maybe. And he has a wife who had committed suicide and there's a lot of talk about his involvement with that. And he wants to create a jogging path in our little suburb and I'm, you know, the cantankerous writer, I'm the only one who objects and it's dumb but he can't let it go and he insists. And he
婚姻解体，分崩离析，我在创作上陷入了瘫痪。我无法产出任何作品，在这个华丽但被忽视、需要大量修缮的房子里晃荡，突然我付不起钱了。突然这个男人搬到了隔壁，他是一个相当有争议的人物，像一个房地产大亨，你知道，非常有名，非常有钱，而且，你知道，可能有点问题。他有一个自杀的妻子，关于他与此事的牵连有很多传言。他想在我们的小郊区建一条慢跑道，而我，你知道，那个脾气暴躁的作家，我是唯一反对的人，这很蠢，但他无法放手，他坚持。而且他
insists on taking me out to lunge to persuade me to, you know, agree to this thing. And we get to, And then suddenly we were sort of repelled by each other, or I certainly am of him, but weirdly, like, kind of excited by each other also. A little dangerous. And I tell this story about my son and the guy who's responsible was just under the limit when he finally had, you know, the breathalyzer done and, you know, and was never held accountable and still lives in town. And he can see, I've kind of avoided feeling the difficult feelings
坚持带我出去吃午饭来说服我，你知道，同意这件事。我们到了，然后突然我们被彼此排斥，或者我肯定是被他排斥，但奇怪的是，也对彼此感到兴奋。有点危险。我讲了这个关于我儿子的故事，那个负责的家伙在最终进行呼吸测试时刚好在限度之下，你知道，而且从未被追究责任，仍然住在镇上。他能看出来，我一直在回避感受那些困难的情绪，
and just fixated all of my grief on this man and that man has committed suicide. And I don't know what to think of that. And I decide to write a book about him and really as a way to figure out if he did in fact kill this guy on my behalf. But also because he just wakes me up creatively. It's dark. This is dark and troubling.
只是把我所有的悲伤都集中在这个男人身上，而那个男人自杀了。我不知道该怎么想。我决定写一本关于他的书，实际上是为了弄清楚他是否真的代表我杀了那个家伙。但也因为他只是在创作上唤醒了我。这很黑暗。这很黑暗且令人不安。
I think the most troubling thing about it is produced by Conan O'Brien. That to me, that he got his grubby little. fingers in here because you're a massive talent. You want to talk about a talent free. Talk about a job. Big red comes in. This son of a bitch. But it's kind of like a cat and mouse story and it's
我认为最令人不安的是它是由柯南·奥布莱恩制作的。对我来说，他把那双肮脏的小手伸进这里，因为你是一个巨大的天才。你想谈论毫无天赋？谈谈工作吧。大红人来了。这个狗娘养的。但这有点像猫捉老鼠的故事，而且……
a little hitchcockian and it's fun. Yeah, it looks great. What a great scene partner you got there with all those scenes of Matthew. It's just so great. It's like the snake and the mongoose. Did you guys know each other beforehand? You and Matthew? No. No. But just a
有点希区柯克风格，很有趣。是的，看起来很棒。你和马修演对手戏真是太棒了。就像蛇和猫鼬。你们之前认识吗？你和马修？不。不。但只是一个……
dream boat. Right? I mean, it's the loveliest team. Charming, kind, and talented. So smart and so very good at what he does. Very good. With the acting business. Easy. No, I like it.
梦中情人，对吧？我的意思是，这是最可爱的团队。迷人、善良且有才华。非常聪明，而且非常擅长他所做的事情。非常好。演艺事业。容易。不，我喜欢它。
Nice guy. He's a great guy. Yeah. You're taking well. Okay. Back on. And you're back with Howard Gordon there, yeah? Yeah.
好人。他是个很棒的人。是的。你做得很好。好的。回来。你又和霍华德·戈登在一起了，对吧？是的。
Yeah, that was fun. Very, very cool. Who's Howard Gordon? He was one of the creators of Homeland. Oh, that's great. Yeah. And he did 24 and X-Files. Well, listen, we owe you three minutes and 40 seconds.
是的，那很有趣。非常非常酷。霍华德·戈登是谁？他是《国土安全》的创作者之一。哦，那太棒了。是的。他还做了《24小时》和《X档案》。好吧，听着，我们欠你3分40秒。
We're over. You know, it's like I could violate the time even further. You're fantastic. Thank you for doing this. Oh, my pleasure. This is so fun. Thank you guys. You know.
我们超时了。你知道，就像我可以进一步违反时间一样。你太棒了。谢谢你做这件事。哦，我的荣幸。这太有趣了。谢谢你们。你知道。
Yeah. Everybody watch The Beast and Me. It's on Netflix. The great Claire Daines. Claire, we love you. Thank you. I love you. I love you, too.
是的。大家去看《野兽与我》。在Netflix上。伟大的克莱尔·丹妮丝。克莱尔，我们爱你。谢谢。我也爱你。我也爱你。
Thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. All right. by, I don't know how to do this. Slam it.
非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。好的。再见，我不知道该怎么做。挂断。
The thing, right? Slam it! Claire Daines. Lovely, lovely woman. Been a part of our world for a very long time. That's 30 plus years. I know.
那个，对吧？挂断！克莱尔·丹妮丝。可爱，可爱的女人。在我们的世界里待了很长时间。那是30多年了。我知道。
My so-called life when it was on MTV was such a huge show for, you know, our age. I mean, it was like a game change. It was like our Dawson's Creek. You know what I mean? Anybody? Ready?
《我所谓的生活》在MTV播出时对我们这个年龄段的人来说是一部巨大的剧。我的意思是，那是一个游戏规则的改变者。那就像我们的《道森溪》。你知道我的意思吗？有人吗？准备好了？
Seventh Heaven, Dawson's Creek. I got to say, I missed it. Oh, I loved it. Which is not too surprising. It came out. Here he comes. Wasn't Jared Leto in that too? Yeah, that was a two of them, wasn't it?
《第七天堂》，《道森溪》。我不得不说，我错过了。哦，我爱死它了。这并不奇怪。它出来了。他来了。杰瑞德·莱托也在里面吗？是的，那是他们两个，对吧？
Yeah. That's right. Yeah. Isn't that crazy? What a couple. Yeah. No, she's been, I just, you know, this is a hard business. It's even harder for women for some stupid, unfair reason.
是的。没错。是的。那不是很疯狂吗？真是一对。是的。不，她一直，我只是，你知道，这是一个艰难的行业。由于某些愚蠢、不公平的原因，这对女性来说更难。
And the fact that she's stayed so relevant. at such a high level, doing such great work. Yes, since she was a kid. And stuff that ain't easy. It's really, really admirable. She's had an incredible career thus far and seems not anywhere near done. She's a big deal. She's one of the great.
事实上，她保持了如此高的相关性，在如此高的水平上，做着如此伟大的工作。是的，从她还是个孩子的时候起。而且这并不容易。这真的，真的很令人钦佩。到目前为止，她拥有令人难以置信的职业生涯，而且看起来远未结束。她是个大人物。她是伟大的演员之一。
She's just got a big life in general. She's got three kids and she's doing so much. We didn't even get into her charity work that she and her mom do for the women of Afghanistan too, which is pretty cool. But what a delight. What a delight. You know, I mean, you know, guys, it's not that hard.
她总的来说生活很丰富。她有三个孩子，她做了很多事情。我们甚至没有谈到她和她妈妈为阿富汗妇女所做的慈善工作，这也非常酷。但真是令人高兴。真是令人高兴。你知道，我的意思是，你知道，伙计们，这并不难。
If you guys just concentrate a little bit more, you could be charismatic. You could be warm. You could be, you know, people that people want to talk to and are charmed by after you're done speaking to them. There's no way. No, I think you could do it. Of course you could never do it.
如果你们再稍微集中一点注意力，你们也可以很有魅力。你们可以很温暖。你们可以，你知道，成为人们想交谈的人，在你们说完话后被你们吸引。不可能。不，我想你能做到。当然你永远做不到。
Yes, she could. I want you to listen to this interview back and just focus on her. And just focus on just her magnetism, okay? She's just engaging and she listens. How am I ever going to do it? How am I ever going to do it? I'm just trying to think of a bye
是的，她能。我希望你听听这次采访，只关注她。只关注她的磁力，好吗？她很有吸引力，而且她会倾听。我怎么可能做到？我怎么可能做到？我只是在想一个再见。
I'm just trying to stall for you Sean I'm reading my bye No Sean go to the last You know what I'm doing I'm just I'm hanging I'm hanging
我只是在为你拖延时间，肖恩，我在读我的再见。不，肖恩，去最后。你知道我在做什么，我只是在挂着，我在挂着。
I'm hanging Bye By About what Coming up with a bye Come up with a bye Come in with a bye I'll love it
我在挂着。再见。关于什么？想出一个再见。想出一个再见。想出一个再见。我会喜欢的。
Bye Smart Smart Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barbago. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。Smartless是100%有机的，由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾夫和本内特·巴巴戈手工制作。Smartless。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。